this is a really foundational Topic in
advanced mathematics and even though
it's like a new word I promise you've
actually met this idea before so I
reckon it won't take us too long to sort
of get up to speed with the ideas and
then you'll get to a point where you're
like ah oh let's just move forward a bit
quicker but I don't want to do that yet
just in case I'm like I I go too fast
for you okay so
um the idea of a function is really
simple right it's just about having some
value input into something you know
something happens and it could be
anything right and then you get an
output that's it
now this thing that makes something
happen is what we call
the function right so you actually know
a whole variety of different
mathematical mathematical functions
already by the time you're in year 11.
so for example let's actually do one
right if I took a number like say three
and then I said hey the thing I want you
to do this this process I'm going to ask
you to do is to multiply that number by
itself right we have a name for that
process right what would you call that
squaring right so we might say this is a
function that squares things and Yen
input you now put which is of course
nine okay happy times this is a very
simple function let me give you a
slightly more complicated one I might
say hey we've got um we've got a shape
here right here's a cylinder okay now if
I wanted to work out the volume of this
cylinder there's two measurements that
you need to know right firstly you're
gonna need to know how tall it is what's
the other measurement you need to know
the area of this surface area okay so
it's going to have to do with the um
like this is just sort of like a flat
measurement but you need to know
something about this right now if you
had that area there what you could work
out which you could use that to work out
is the radius and then with these two
things see these are inputs so I'm going
to say R and H the radius and the height
you would put that into a particular
kind of function for the cylinder it'll
be the volume function and then you'd
get a volume at the end okay now in this
case do you actually know what the
volume of a cylinder is I put something
out of render that's okay
um the volume of a cylinder or maybe
yeah four-wheeler yeah just the formula
perfect bam okay so what you've got here
right what you've correctly identified
is here's a formula all you need to do
is take whatever those values are
substitute them in and then you get some
answer at the end so these things here
in the middle these are the functions
okay so let me introduce and this is
worth writing down right let's introduce
a bit of notation
so
because these are all called functions
we use the letter F A lot and it just
abbreviates function right so uh this
one here right this thing that's squared
things I might say okay this is the
input and this is like your your x value
okay this is what you're going to put in
and then this thing here it's like oh
it's just um you take that number
and you multiply it by itself so you
would write that as x squared okay so
the name of this or the way that we
would denote this and you might have
seen some of this in the textbook is I
would say for example
um f with the bracket X right equals x
squared now super important to just
pause on this for a minute have you seen
this before yeah
um
yeah yeah yeah sure now I just want to
hover on this for a minute because
um
mathematicians really lazy
um they want to write things very
succinctly and efficiently but for that
reason sometimes they will um you know
how in English
I'm trying to think of a good example
for you right
um in English sometimes a single word
means two things at the same time and
you have to work out based on context
which one it means right so if I said
the word day
d-a-y right you're like oh
do you mean that's 24 hours
or do you mean just
the time when the Sun is up
now those are related but actually quite
different aren't they right
um night and day versus
um days months weeks Etc how would it
tell whether it was one or the other
um it depends what was in front of it
very good yeah it just depends on like
this context around this that indicates
to you okay now the exact same thing is
happening here if I didn't give you any
context whatsoever and I said there's a
letter
and then brackets and something inside
if for instance I gave you something
like this
this
please suggest to you like that there's
an operation that you would do between
these what would you guess the operation
yeah multiplication is kind of implied
there right so in this case you just say
oh 15 right so the context here of of
numbers tells you it's multiplication
but here and particularly the fact that
they use this letter if they'll use
other ones as well
um
G is the letter after F comes up a whole
lot sometimes they'll use U or V but
this context tells you there's not
multiplication actually happening this
is a name of a function I'm just going
to call it f
and the thing it tells you to do is
square things okay so that's one example
let's give you another one
it's this one that you just did here
right so this here is a function that
does what what did it
very good so in this case you would say
well why don't we just call the function
like a name that is a bit more
descriptive right and then what you put
in these brackets are the thing that
goes in it's the input right very good
so it's R and H and in this case it
would be pi r squared H okay now I've
given you these kinds of examples here
because the basic idea is just there are
inputs
inputs you do something to those inputs
and you'll get some answer at the end
like say nine or I don't know uh if this
was a radius of 10 I'll let you write
this down ready so 10 a height of seven
then my volume
would be equal to Pi times 10 squared
times seven
hundred Pi does that make sense so
there's an there's inputs there's
outputs okay now nicely for you just
realize I didn't bring in a whiteboard
eraser and I'm going to get one a second
lucky for you see how this function has
two inputs we're pretty much exclusively
going to stay in the the realm of uh
functions which have one input and
actually if you just have a look you've
got the textbook open yeah you're going
to see and I want you to give me an
example actually
give me an example of a function they're
giving you and let F bracket Open
Bracket x equals bracket equal two X
plus three
great okay so you can see all of the
pieces of the puzzle mentioned before
right are in here um there's a function
it's just called f not very original
the input number is here and by the way
we don't have to call it that we could
have had F of C I had radius and height
I could have um I might have an input
that's like y instead of X and it would
be you put in y's instead of x's okay
and then this is the uh this is the Box
this is the function that does things to
the number Okay now what's it asking for
like they said this is the function what
have they then asked you to do with it
say that again volume of x they want a
value of x
read see does it calculate yep so you
have to find X and then put in the
equation okay very good so they would
say calculate and then I presume I'm
guessing they're going to give you
different values of X and then they want
to know what is the what's the output
yeah right um can you give me an example
what's what's one of the values of X
they want you to do first one is one
okay so if they said if x equals one
right so the way we would write this
again I'm trying to introduce the
notation to you is we would just put
that one wherever we see X right so that
would literally lead to well the first X
is right there so I'm going to say and I
read this as f
of one in fact you know what this
reminds me of and I wonder if you recall
this from years ago maybe three years
back do you remember we used to do well
you'll later on you'll do some more um
probability like rolling dice stuff like
that did you ever encounter this
um yeah like like heads or tails or
something like that right now when
you're writing the probability very good
now this is actually kind of function
notation it's the probability of this
right so what we're going to do is f of
that so again I'm actually just going to
put in one wherever I saw X okay so I'm
going to go to
there's eggs right there plus three can
you evaluate for me
um it would be f o r f of one equals two
plus three which is five fantastic I'm
just gonna go straight to five I think
we can handle that right
um so that's really good one time now
it's really sneaky right even just in
one line
we're using this notation kind of
differently right because you knew
correctly that that was multiplication
but here it's function notation yeah did
you have a question just there oh no
yeah it's a bit it's a bit funny okay um
did they give you another number like
we've got x equals one so that's the end
that's it that's that's all there is to
it right so the inputs here in fact I
might just highlight that
uh
and here's the output yeah and in the
middle is a function slash process yeah
that's right this this here really is
that is that function or like you said
it's just a it's just a process with
some algebra right and you can put
anything you know in there so you know
over the last 11 years uh you've learned
you could put in square roots you could
put trigonometry you could put
logarithms any of that stuff can fit in
here so that that word function uh that
process is very very broad can it quit
anything okay
now just before I ask you to give me
another example in a minute I actually
just want to press on this example for a
minute
so you see how we said if x equals one
go ahead and work out the output right
you can make x equal to anything so for
example I want you to see if you can
help me work out here right if I said to
you what if we made x equal to
not a number
but another pronumeral right so for
instance I could put in say for instance
let's be um let's be a bit weird here
let's put in a squared there oh God now
you don't need to fret because they've
given you a pretty easy example here but
I'm going to do and I wonder if you can
help me here right I'm going to do
exactly the same thing I did with one
I'm just going to do with a squared okay
so it's still going to be two
um of something plus three yeah that's
right so just before we get there right
I'm going to write it from the beginning
so I'm going to write F of what a
squared right exactly equals two two
yeah I'm so glad you actually said that
because this is the P where it's like oh
yes where do I put this a squared and
the answer is anywhere you see X and
only where you see X so it actually is a
very common thing to say like oh do I
put another thing here and the answer is
no that three just sits by itself yeah
okay
let me give it that's right it's like oh
I instinctively put stuff there let me
give you one more example okay and let's
see how you go what if x were equal to
uh let's do this let's go
you
take away seven
okay now here it's not just a number
it's not just a single algebraic term
I've given you like a few things right
so it's going to be F of U minus U minus
seven great and then what
um it's going to be 2 U minus
two U minus 14. oh very good so you've
actually
um you've expanded all in one hit that's
great because what you did was the whole
thing
was multiplied by two which is perfect
right and then what and then my plus
three very good so that plus three just
kind of hangs out on the end in fact
what you'll notice by the way let me get
a new color
is that plus three is kind of um
it's it never changes right it's it's
sort of like no matter what you put into
X it never it never uh gets affected and
so yeah yeah so if you say that instance
we have negative 14 and uh three not get
added to it oh yeah so let's let's go
ahead and complete it right so the first
line
um and it's worth calling it out as this
right this is what we call the the
substitution line because all you've
done
is not leave enough space on the
Internet is you've put in U minor seven
right and then often it is the case that
there's simplifying to do so don't go
ahead and simplify that for me to my uh
two minus 11. bam done so that's the
output this is the input does that make
sense yeah
okay fantastic now just last thing to
mention here I was just highlighting how
that plus three is the same every time
um we've got a word for when something
doesn't ever change starts with a C do
you know the word
hmm things are um they're either they
either vary which are these they're
variables or they are
constant constants that's why we call
them constants because no matter
um what you do no matter what you put in
that plus three is always just going to
be plus three yeah make sense yeah